[Music]
stanford university
the topic of today's session is
investing in early stage emerging
technology companies
context is frontier technology can take
a long time to reach the market and they
usually require a substantial amount of
capital relative to other startup ideas
we'll look at venture capital's role in
developing these new emerging
technologies challenges implications
trends
limitations to funding these companies
excited to introduce our three speakers
we've all known each other for about the
past 10 years or so but it's the first
time everyone's on a panel together i'll
introduce barris first he's a general
partner at aba
ventures he was formerly an investor at
intel capital
as well as at google heading up global
strategic business development in the
media and entertainment vertical he
joined google um since he was a cfo a
startup that was acquired by google he
started his career as a product manager
and engineer
also we have julia here today she's a
general partner at breakout ventures
breakout ventures is a venture fund that
was cooked up by julia and her partners
when they first ran breakout labs which
is a seed fund within peter thiel's
foundation and prior to breakout
ventures julia held a number of
operational and investment roles at
various life science companies and
finally we also have patrick he was a
three-time olympian swimmer he currently
runs acario innovation which is a
venture fund backed by tokyo gas he was
also an investor at dbl partners also an
executive at samsung both on their
corporate audit team as well as global
strategy groups so ferris julia patrick
thank you all for joining us today the
format for today's panel will provide
some definitions
background overview of frontier
technology as it relates to venture
capital and then really dive into the
investment process including evaluation
and due diligence
as well as post investment portfolio
management so
um open up to the panel
first off how do you define
frontier technology emerging technology
startups compared to other types of
early stage companies
i'll take a first crack at it and also
say i think it's pretty fluid i've
always worked in areas of so my whole
career has been operating and investing
in life sciences and
so you end up being pretty deep in
technology just being in life sciences
in general and we go across i would say
our angle within deep tech is biology
and chemistry and so it ends up in
genome cell therapy a lot of things in
bio bioengineering and a lot of
neuromodulation neuro chemistry new
biomaterials new biochemicals
biodefense all that kind of stuff so
what i usually end up looking at as
maybe the deep tech part of it is
there's some enabling technology outside
of the the core product that enabled
this to be
a a venture
relevant
time frame and scale but it's also why
it's so exciting and scalable right so
it can be everything that's happened in
ai and ml and computer vision and
automation um within tech everything
that's happened in sequencing and
genetic engineering within life sciences
looking at the miniaturization of
sensors all of that is enabling me to go
deeper in one area of science and get to
scale on a huge market
so that's how i look at it
very similar to julia and i don't look
at biotech or healthcare but mostly on
maybe other kind of technologies around
automation and the way we define it
again everyone has a different
way of describing this and deeptek just
by itself it's a bit weird term there
are people who are playing il platforms
doing really interesting analytics
solutions with very deep technologies at
the back end
but the way we describe it is
it's at first there's going to be a
massive technology risk we're taking the
technology is not
putting together building blocks from
certain areas so there's a deep
technology risk that means there's a lot
of ip and that kind of diligence that
needs to be done second it's a really
long path to commercialization just
because of the nature of the technology
it's all driven by the technology it
takes a long time to develop i don't
know an autonomous truck or a satellite
or some kind of a semiconductor chip or
some kind of quantum computing hence it
takes a long time to get to the revenue
that means you need to finance
throughout that time so the combination
of those kind of like for us is deep
tech and that could be in many
categories and healthcare is i guess by
definition is one of them like biotech
and i see my focus and at least our
funds focus has been around
space manufacturing technologies
autonomous trucking different uav
technologies and so that's where we see
deep tech on from that vantage point
yeah i'll add ironically within certain
areas of life sciences because there's
always been huge science
technical risk i actually think of a lot
of deep tech being faster i i could do
it in the beginning of my career took 10
years in a year easily so it's funny how
it might offset other risks within the
same product
we don't have embarrassment i don't have
clinical trials to go through you tell
people sometimes uh
autonomous driving same issue yeah so hi
everybody thanks again just a quick
background on a carry to frame my answer
which is going to be very similar to
baris and julia's so akari is the
captive corporate venture arm for tokyo
gas corp in tokyo japan japan's biggest
gas utility looking at and they set up a
carrier to tap into the startup
ecosystem here in the states and get
ready for this energy transition first
off we don't do any fossil fuels
we're trying to get them off the fossil
fuels and it's a long road
but the areas that we're looking at are
basically in decarbonization and
hydrogen all the grid 2.0 stuff which is
the distributed renewable network of
networks grid so we're talking industry
transformation from central generation
hub and spoke to a grid that's looks a
lot like california's or texas and
transportation electrification mobility
and be coming from an industry where
there's not a lot of technology or it
applied the application of iot and
sensors and all what's called industry
4.0 thank you mckinsey to making
industrial operations better it helps
that i'm an electrical engineer a
material scientist by training with
degrees from cal and stanford yes i did
the craft space shuffle but for us deep
tech and even at dbl has been frontier
technologies are things that are
new potentially breaking laws of physics
but ultimately things that require a lot
of
science and then following the science
engineering to turn into products even
before you get to market an example is
battery chemistries and things one of my
former partners said
as a rule of thumb it takes 10 or so
years and 100 million dollars of
invested capital to get a battery to
market
and unfortunately at my last firm we
lived through that and many recap rounds
in a long time it's good but a lot of
the innovations that we're looking at
particularly energy sector are
immature and require a lot of money to
scale so that they can come down in
price and maybe two of the classic
examples of that are the cost of wind
and solar like today you can get wind
and solar for
two cents or less per kilowatt hour on
utility scale contracts and 25 cents per
watt or so for pv panels but 10 years
ago it was easily 10x that so there's a
long learning curve and a lot of time
and when you think about that as an
investor you need to have longer time
horizons and the life cycle of a 10-year
fund doesn't always match up with that
and when you're evaluating these deep
tech startups and the science as patrick
just caught it and you're assessing the
technology risks how do you conduct
diligence on the technology especially
when the founder can be the leading
expert in the field who wants to start
are you asking me it's we all there's a
number of things you can do so starting
with and the first thing is to realize
that even though there are a lot of
smart people in venture you don't know
everything and not everybody remembers
that sometimes so find really smart
people who are in related areas that you
can talk to mernistein history if it's
something truly novel the founder or the
initial scientist developer might be the
world's expert but typically for us
they've gone through something like the
nrel or arpa e programs at the national
labs and there'll be people that we can
reference sometimes we'll bring in
outside experts as well and you bring up
a good point technology is not
everything to ernestine because you
still have to productize that and turn
it into a business we get help and ask
smart people that we know if it's
something in healthcare i'll ask julia
if it's something in
it or enterprise sas i'll call up paris
and say hey who do you know what do you
think about this and the danger is
really that you see so many things and
if you're not sufficiently diligent you
can go chase after a shiny penny that is
um
not what it seems to be
yeah
and i'll say something that's the
opposite of venturesmart which is we
have the coolest job in the world which
is we get to learn for a living and we
get to deploy large amounts of money and
we get to be on boards and keep on
getting smarter while we're doing it and
so i think of my job
as frankly
i just have to
stay close to and continue to talk to as
many brilliant people a day as i
possibly can and because especially the
range of things that we work on i will
never be the world's leading expert on
the integration of hematology driven
cell therapies that are using
electroporation for in vivo gene therapy
like there's so many specific niches on
the technical side that i think that
what you really like we have to really
do well is i'll look at something where
i'll be looking at a
bio aspect of technical risk like
biology and by the way biology is like
way harder than
anything
with this because it never does what you
think it's going to do and then i will
bring an ai
specialist in datasets that she can call
on
sorry she can call bs on the hey they
think that this data set is actually
going to be able to drive a scalable
product and so we end up having it
often times especially in different
areas
like the technical risk is in like there
isn't just one silo of risk right it's
the integration of all these
technologies that is the risk so
sometimes you're looking at the does
this thing do the thing it says it's
gonna do and then sometimes you're like
how i can repeat this like in a lab or
in this pilot but i have no clue how i'm
going to make this
a cost-effective scalable solution for a
huge fortune 500 company so you're
looking at both sides of technical risk
in that and oftentimes we we hope that
the founders are leading experts in in
the niche that we're exploiting that's
at this perfect inflection point but you
have to get input from different angles
and then often the input that we get
from different angles if we're serious
about doing that investment we're also
saying hey who could we hire
to complement this team because there's
no way this founding team
isn't gonna have that that expert on
staff over time yeah the only thing i'm
gonna add is i think julian uh patrick
covered the main pieces it's and it's
when you do the diligence on this kind
of things it's really you have the
holistic approach just because the
science works doesn't mean that we could
make money or this company is going to
be good i mean or the product works
there is a market for it
so it's like really looking at all those
components science technology the
product and the market and you also judy
and patrick already mentioned these the
one thing i will add is
you go look for a lot of data points and
that's as a venture capitalist you're
not the smartest in the room you have
this delusion of knowledge but it's it's
you have an amazing network right that's
our biggest advantage we got to the
right people quickly to go through this
and that's our advantage other than that
i don't know anything about the
synthetic aperture radar i need to go
deep to someone who spent 10 years on it
and so that's one the second thing i
will say and you're gonna take all this
feedback with a grain of salt right it's
the tendency at least in my career so
far i see a lot of experts being way
more pessimistic and this whole nih type
attitude towards some of the
technologies that they haven't worked on
so you got to be a bit more i guess um
cautious when you're getting those kind
of feedback like this typical will be oh
this will never work they can't make it
work oh even if it works people won't
buy it and so that's what i see with the
from the technical people and on the
product side i see a lot more optimism
as a potential buyer when you do the
market diligence people like oh yeah if
they have it we'll buy it i don't know
who said that but for an ambient product
there is an infinite demand right
everyone says they will buy it because
stated behavior versus observed behavior
they will say they will buy it when you
have it very few people will write the
check so you've got to be very up you
know cautious in getting those feedback
from both sides so with the technical
people who are very usually pessimistic
you've got to be careful what the
product side that optimism may not turn
into revenue so you've got to be careful
how do you read that feedback from the
market side
i'll add one example to
varsh's comment on pessimism's ernestine
intro i built and still run a portfolio
of 50 investments for peter deal all in
deep tech all this sort of cutting edge
of science all all of those were
preceded receive deals so like really
early stage really crazy stuff i
actually did like a bunch of these guys
have seen some of it like maybe it went
a little too far sometimes and
we actually tried to do up here because
we were doing it years ago before it was
as competitive too we actually tried to
do peer review to give some credibility
to the scientific diligence and we did
it for all 50 companies so we would
invite because that's our network we
would bring in academics and different
sort of level peer review as if this
were like a nature paper or whatever
else and it's interesting how
pessimistic those folks are because also
remember a lot of specialists have spent
the last decade working on something
else and then if you're showing them
something that in theory could be better
they're usually gonna hate it
that happens all the time oh related to
the diligence process assume the science
works it's amazing how do you then
assess the regulatory hurdles needed to
get to market to actually generate that
revenue for example in biopharma julia
you're looking at fda trials or for
autonomous vehicles blockchain who knows
when they'll be fully regulated how do
you think about those somewhat
unpredictable regulatory hurdles and how
does that affect your investment
decision i'll go with the autonomous
trucking one which we've done in 2018
and i spent
some time with the regulatory folks
trying to understand what will happen in
the in terms of licenses for for
autonomous trucking across united states
it's a very complicated issue so there's
science piece we just talked and then
the regulator piece at least for
autonomous trucking was almost as
complicated as the science part where
every state has different rules for
different type of autonomy and for
testing and for a live they have
different expectations the timelines
were different we talked to a number of
folks
from the regulatory side we talked a
number of lawyers try to understand how
to interpret all this stuff but at the
end of the day
you make a call based on the data that
we have and and and have some
understanding of what the downside what
will be our outcome as a fund in that
kind of a downside scenario and we were
comfortable with that situation and that
we went ahead but there is enough
ambiguity in that regulatory landscape
that it could easily paralyze you not to
do the investment so you at the end of
the day this is venture capital we take
risk and when we take the risk there's
some calculated risk behind it which is
okay if california never accepts it
is there are there enough routes across
the united states that where this
company can get to x million dollar
revenue so that's like the thinking how
we go through that and we were
comfortable with the fact that there are
enough states out there that are so far
ahead in terms of regulatory environment
that we will be able to get these trucks
on the road in the near future
one heuristic and we don't always go by
heuristics but one thing we've learned
is like regulate try not to invest in
anything that requires regulation to
make it work because you're going to be
in for a hard long ride if you can find
products that people are willing to buy
that don't depend on that that's great
that said in the energy space where i
live today the market economics are
totally driven by regulation and ability
to access markets we at dbl we spent a
lot of time with solarcity talking to
different state legislators about
allowing net metering and not letting
utilities shut it down so that there
would be market development for
solarcity a time in front of cpuc and
california energy commission trying to
get different regulations set up to
enable
business models for distributed energy
resources and energy services
and today we look at a lot of these
immature carbon capture technologies and
people are saying you need a carbon tax
about 100 bucks a ton plus to make it
economic well
that's
not a good thing to be going into so on
the one embarrasses you have to make a
choice is this does can this technology
capture a big market
create good profits part of which is
driven by regulation and drive the fund
returns that we're all looking for and
that we're
as jplp investors fiduciary are
responsible to our lps for can you
return three to five extra funds so
regulation ends up being a lot about
market access and timing and economics
and
it's a
risk but in many cases it's an own risk
but it's going to change like with julie
is dealing with the fda and there's a
process for filing and filing your data
all and it's a long one
but if you know how to go through it and
you have good relationships with the
examiners you can get through that i
think it's more fun on panels when
people disagree so i'll say i disagree
no i actually
need
a strategic advantage and especially
from the areas that i work in so in and
not everything that i do is farming
it's like the most easy business model
slash playbook that everyone knows right
but
it's
no one can go it once you get into the
clinics so regulatory advantage so if
you're thinking about something that's a
gene or cell therapy if you have the
advantage of having better insight on
the clinical pre-clinical regulatory
path early then you actually can block
out competitors you can grab subsets of
patient populations that will outperform
you can grab those patients earlier in
rare diseases like there's all sorts of
ways that you can use that advantage and
i have actually you guys everyone here
knows jenny a co-investor of mine one of
her lines is give me the fda over a
consumer any day right like consumers
are fickle all that market caps gone if
they turn on you the fda doesn't turn on
you in the same way it's a little bit
more known and then on the other side of
that the thing that i probably learned
in my career is now that i'm like in
those conversations a little bit more
and on the boards of these companies
that are doing cutting-edge technologies
and i can really see the fda
conversations playing out more
intimately
it isn't always a known process you can
influence the fda right like you can get
ahead of it you can request pre-ind
meetings you can have people advocating
for you in rare diseases and in certain
areas like that's the difference between
if you just take the playbook it's four
years and if you push the push push push
you can do it in
two and a half years or two years i
think it can actually be an advantage
sometimes to get you ahead of
competitors i mean one thing we haven't
talked about is the patent side like as
is almost as powerful as the regulatory
side like i agree with to you about the
once you get the approval it becomes a
big barrier event to others
and the patent is similar right in
certain ways especially with this deep
tech
investments patent portfolio it's for us
the patent diligence but for the founder
the patent portfolio becomes a very
important competitive advantage there
are companies who create a patent
minefield for anyone to walk through to
not get close to their core
product and technology so it's a smart
way and also a deeply defensible way of
differentiating the market question from
the class do you think the rise of
stacks will influence the funding of
early stage deep tech companies putting
just some context around that spec is
something that
started to emerge over the last few
months which stands for special purpose
acquisition company it's a way for
companies to go public without going
through the traditional ipo process
through these blank check shell
corporations it really propelled for
instance the electric car market going
public so question for the panel do you
think the rises facts will influence the
funding of early stage deep tech company
influence funding versus good idea are
two very different
answers i think they're a horrible idea
for most deep tech companies because the
thing that no one is doing the math on
is being like going public through space
or raising through spec you still have
to go public and i'm sorry if anyone
else really enjoyed reading the quantum
scopes back like
perspective that was horrific there are
so many years until revenue so you don't
want to be a public company with that
outlook so i just feel like some of
those are gonna
some of them will be great i'm sure of
it but i definitely feel like that's
gonna blow up for some folks because you
just you don't have the
metrics to actually be running a public
company
and julia you still have to do stocks
compliance you have all the costs
associated with that for some firms
let's say that this way there's
popularity and there's an ipo window up
in the market and people are tapping
public markets for some firms it allows
them to get the capital they couldn't
raise in the private markets to actually
execute on the plan and maybe at the end
of that time they will have achieved it
and it was a way for them to do that
particularly if you have like to build
expensive infrastructure like ev
charging stations or something
for a lot of companies that we look at
we a lot of us scratch our heads okay
and uh the ev oem is getting an average
two billion dollar post money valuation
and some of these companies have no
route to product no route to profits
let alone and revenues let alone profits
and how long are
they going to last
when they're not gonna be able to tap
into it again if they can't execute and
for others like a charge point that
makes sense you've gone public you've
tapped public markets you get additional
growth capital without necessarily
having to go through the roadshow and
one thing in spax that's interesting is
you can talk about forward-looking plans
which you can't do
on an sec roadshow typically for an ipo
so
it's a mixed bag it's just another tool
that people are taking you advantage of
and it has to make sense like any other
financing decision
yeah but if you couldn't have if you
wouldn't have otherwise considered going
public then you probably shouldn't be
going through
comparing like is this faster cheaper
easier way to go public if not all go
public but if you didn't have that
option i shouldn't be with you
one impact of that i guess is gonna
increase the appetite for early stage
investors
to get into the market which is positive
for uh deep tech because what they're
gonna see is as judea and patrick
mentioned the number of companies who
went public through that path spec
and so it's been cr decreased the time
to exit for some of the early stage
investors and some put some at least
numbers on the scoreboard in terms of
comparables
and now seed stage investor will be more
willing
to invest in those kind of companies
because there is a path this will
continue until
to julia's point it will crash right
because at the end you are becoming a
public company that you need to deliver
on a quarterly basis and revenues and is
nature of these businesses
when they are going public if you look
at some of them are all 24 25 like
four-year ahead revenue multiples so
that is
today's market if you know there's any
contract in the market that's not gonna
happen so they need to deliver revenue
and then there's a huge correction
for kind of companies so both public
investors and probably the founding team
will unfortunately not benefit from that
but i can see a time window where it
works out well for deep tech founders
for early stage investors this liquidity
continues
yeah i'll add one more thing baris which
is it from the perspective of the
company it's actually a decent thing
because they end up keeping most of the
control in the merged entity the
original company as an investor buyer
beware and
sure interest rates are zero but they
won't be forever
and some this party will also crash at
some point because and those that aren't
really ready to be public companies will
go down yeah you could be also picked up
as gamestop i'm not sure if you are
following what's going on with gamestop
with some reddit uh crowd just piling on
a stock and just skyrocketing because of
the short interest what if you get
caught into something like that it's yes
you have control but you're public now
anyone can do any kind of stuff through
either what gamestop is going through or
some like activist investor it's a
totally different game once you're in
public i don't have that kind of
expertise on the public markets
but today it's very attractive because
of the liquidity and these companies
need a lot of capital to get to where
they want to go and that money is coming
cheap if that continues yeah it's
fantastic for deep tech another question
from the class are we in a bubble now
obviously we're all seeing very high
valuations for
companies that don't have revenue
sometimes they don't even have a product
are we in a bubble
i just i think actually all three of us
were investing
in the last downturn so i haven't seen
launch parties with the bet you're in a
hubble when you're only customers or
other venture-backed companies
that's a problem i'm not sitting here
trying to be an economist i can tell you
what other investors say with rlps say
which are mostly
billionaires and some living theater and
then some multi-billion institutions and
the
this isn't my insight but interest rates
at zero where else you gonna put your
money it just keeps going risk and that
that shifts over time with interest
rates but i actually unlike i think the
last
when i was investing in life sciences in
the last downturn that was long long
time period lots of capital
risk like you had everything working
against you and like i said the ability
to pull in some things and maybe might
help deep tech and more technical
companies a little bit better into
whether that storm and i think there's
definitely more permanent capital in
some of these spaces just the way that
there's more seed funds there's more
corporate there's more family office
activity there's all sorts of different
ways to find a company that would
survive a little bit better than last
time i think i i i i agree with julia
it's it's no one knows but the zero rate
zero interest rate environment
definitely brings a lot of the
cash and bubbles are always hindsight in
the outside it's very obvious but now
yes things are extremely inflated like
you look at the multiples you look at
what's going on my personal experience
was i think it was 2012
was 2011 i can't remember this was right
after the 2009 crash i met deepmind
folks and they were raising their seed
round at 40 pre
at that time that was unseen and that
was peter who i think led the precede or
something like that because dennis was a
chess prodigy so they apparently met
during a chess tournament so it's it
looked like oh my this is crazy and this
is bubble this company will never go
anywhere and deep mine was a fantastic
investment it could have been even a
bigger company if google didn't acquire
them i think but so it's
when i see the companies now and
especially for founders is it bubble or
not
why do i care as a founder right there
is capital i just need to be if i have a
great idea and there is liquidity if i
act you know responsibly and raise
enough and just execute it really
doesn't matter it's perfect time to race
you just need to have a discipline to be
able to execute to wherever you want to
go with people available and for an
investor it's way harder for us the
entry price like the price points are
increasing so you like pushing out where
we can make money and if that comes down
we don't make money for founders is a
little bit different so for founders the
biggest problem is the inflated wage
major inflation going on in the market
yeah if you leave with fundamentals of
those versions saying focus on your
milestones being what are the value
inflection points in any market not just
in a hot market then usually you
figure it out
i think if is there any one of us like
regretting to invest in a great founder
regardless of downturn or a great number
and buyers you bring up a good point you
have to be continuously disciplined in
your approach and barris brings up
another good point like i started my
career as okay it's all about the market
but over the last 10 years i've realized
it's really about the team you need to
have be in a market that matters
but
we see so many companies and we'll often
see we're looking at this space we
looked at one company hey there's 15
others that are doing the same idea
who's going to win one could argue that
softbank destroyed it a little bit by
dumping a bunch of capital in certain
companies but ultimately it's the really
great founders and teams that find a way
to keep pivoting or keep financing and
keep funding a company
long beyond the date anyone thought it
should have died and then they win and
so we try to find the best teams we can
execute in big markets at least
that's what i've been trying to do
patrick i'm glad you're talking about
market and team since another question
from the class is how do you think about
valuations for pre-revenue deep tech
companies do you ever attempt to make
quantitative estimates of the total
addressable market and work backwards
are you making more gut-based decisions
on the founders the team and the tech
how pre-revenue and pre-product are we
talking about is it like two phd
students in a lab at stanford
yeah
it's tough valuation is not a science
really and it's also in market because
you remember that there are often you're
often competing with people to be a
leading or be even in the syndicate and
get an allocation
even if you have pro rata rights as a
prior investor so
at that early stage of like early
company formation early product it's the
hope and the dream the founders are
telling the hope in the dream this is a
giant market
i'm uniquely suited to tackle this but
and i've identified a problem that if
everything works it could be pretty
lucrative and we could capture a large
part of it and we need and we have a
product and we've tested a little bit
and
a lot is still out of your control you
could have everything go perfectly and
then 2008 comes along and the market
crashes or regulations change and like
something that was allowed
is no longer allowed and your business
model evaporates i don't have a good
answer julia other than finding really
people who
are
pattern recognition is identified as
this is a good founder who can execute
in an interesting market and then trust
them
and go on that journey with them but
assigning a value and doing market what
if the market doesn't exist yet it's
enabled by this product or service how
do you value that
yeah i i'll i'll give it a couple
thousand one i have invested like
started off in public have started
companies i've done later stage like in
my private life i actually put it in
late stage fintech and like all this
other stuff and so the joke is like
the earlier stage you go
you don't have to like the worst you can
be at math maybe like the worst you can
be at excel or whatever right like you
know nobody in a steve funds knows how
to do a macro like they don't even know
how to use anything beyond google sheet
like it's about how much money can i put
in and how much ownership can i have and
i think this is worth
a lot right like it's super simple and
so when you talk about like
how to value something which obviously
we have to do you think a lot about
these ownership things and so
i probably should like we do a lot so we
have a group of i don't know scouts
fellows we always have post docs that
kind of work on with us part time and a
lot of phd founders and so i feel the
need to always like explain how venture
works
and so i talk about i think of six major
bus buckets of risk make up your
discount rate against a really huge
market
and so can you identify that really big
market i think this could be like a
billion something whatever and then what
else technology risk market commercial
risk finance and risk execution or team
risk um and exit risk we think of those
as just like contributing to the
discount rate of whatever that
foundation is and it's really high at
the beginning but then there's some
really interesting stuff to play with
that same idea of like how do you value
something
if anyone knows archventures it's a big
non-five-time investor and also some
areas of
industrial as well but like they
regularly do these new codes with 800
million to a billion raised
and
like essentially all they've done and it
was like how do they do that how do they
price it everything else they just did
all but the technical risk they took
care of everything we're not going to
worry about money we're not going to
worry about team we're not going to
we're going to go after huge markets
like and then all of that focuses on
technical risks so it's this interesting
mix of how many risks are you willing to
date on to and team ends up being the
one that
raises that valuation
another question from the class is how
do you think about timing it right when
it comes to investing in deep tech a lot
of the failed investments indeed tech
are often due to investing too early
before the market was ready to adopt
rather than investing in the wrong
technology i'll add a follow-up question
as well to that and then after you've
made the investment if you realize that
you've invested it too early do you keep
pouring in follow-on capital to support
the company or at what point do you know
that you need to wind down
it's it's a lot the one way to mitigate
against that and at least what we think
we are doing is the voice of the
customer
right if you get the voice of the
customer talk to enough potential
customers with the caveat that they may
change direction they may change their
decision at all but if you talk enough
of them you can get a sense of what the
timeline to commercialization will be so
if there's a product today are the
customers willing to buy today and what
are the hurdles that the company needs
to go through to be able to sell at what
price points and that kind of thing you
could really diligence that by
understanding uh what the company is
doing today to fix that problem or if
this is a groundbreaking technology yeah
i don't know the healthcare part but at
least in the the space like we have a
satellite company which has a
proprietary data set for weather and
just digging there are very few
companies who has that kind of
technology and they have very unique
approach to do it but when you go to the
diligence and talk to many different
verticals and customers you can see if
the accuracy is at the level that the
company think they could get to there's
enough demand so that kind of uh
mitigates that problem are we early or
not but if you are early if we ever do
that which we haven't done yet
it's that's the risk reward profile of
the overall fund like how long were we
willing to go through that path because
there's some companies will take maybe
10 years 12 13 years to get there and
spacex was kudos to founders fund a
friend of ours i think four of ours is
just a fish there i remember him telling
me spacex deal in 2009 because they were
running out of money and i didn't
understand is he joking or if it's real
like are you really investing in rockets
at that time no one was doing it and the
whole world was collapsing and he was
asking for capital for
rockets and they stuck with them for
years with going through a lot of tough
times and now it's obvious
but at that time it wasn't and their
fund has that kind of a risk reward
profile to go through that j curve
and
with our fund which is a smaller fund
180 million dollar fund we don't have
that kind of a risk profile to go
through 10 years of
technology development so we will try
not to do those deals
because you're not the right fit for
those kind of deals but there's some
funds who have
longer horizon with bigger capital that
could take on those risks yeah timing is
tough and the energy space
it's longer which is why you see things
like breakthrough energy ventures have
longer terms and more committed capital
and a lot of family offices coming in to
go after this market opportunity a
10-year fund with two extensions to 12
or 14 years if you get in super early
and remember that quota you know 10
years to get a battery to market
you shouldn't take those investments and
timing is really hard so
you know i was around in the dot-com
boom and i remember as a student
actually at the gsb
and i remember pets.com
and in fact i've got through in our
invest an investment in the real got to
know julie rain right it was the
president really well and julie was like
i know everything there is to go wrong
and today
my wife regularly orders from chewie and
amazon for cat food for our cats so
20 years later the market is there it's
hard to tell and part of our job is to
look around the corner to the future and
have conviction and take a reasoned bet
but it doesn't always work out market
development
can be driven by a lot of different
things and then your second question are
saying when do you cut the cord
that's one of the toughest decisions to
have around a partnership table
because
you have x amount of funds
and your duty is to return capital to
your investors
and you're better off
often piling in money to your winners to
me at 10x double down on tesla double
down on spacex double down on whatever
it is
because you need to return funds
and
there's ones that are dogs that like
lemons ripe and early so praise you
often hear adventure like things that'll
die early and the ones in the middle but
if we only do another round it will get
to this milestone which will unlock this
and
it's a tough call to do and it causes it
can cause a lot of spirited discussion
i'll say in your part where you should
out get things
yeah i'll just uh what bars thought
about the customers and it's like
the timing you don't want to get wrong
is the partner customer potential
acquired and you need to buy yourself
some wiggle room for everything that
will go wrong on the timeline and
technical i reminded examples of
invested in a b-cell therapy or new
modality and cell therapy too early and
the like farmer's head just wasn't there
but like now seriously it's raised a lot
of money among the board and it's calmed
six months from now a billion dollars
now we're there so i've gotten better at
being like okay clearly i overshot some
of that
pharma typically knows most corporates
know
where they want their top line where
they want their investment to be five
years ten years from now like just make
sure you're listening to that and what
feels risky to them versus what feels a
risk they're going to have to take to be
competitive like if i don't invest in
these things but i'm sure everyone's
saying to themselves we have to be in
in my space that's the equivalent of
gene and cell therapy everyone knows in
2025 revenue is going away from top line
and they need to replace it with the
next-gen therapies
you can count just one last earnestly i
think you can pretty much count though
that whatever your investment
memo says it probably is going to take
more time and more capital than you
initially thought to hit certain capital
for
certain milestones definitely so
portfolio management you've made the
investment let's talk about managing and
shepherding that investment first
question how do you measure milestones
and success metrics for these jeep tech
companies over time
for us is mainly driven by key
commercial milestones we're very
commercial focused in that sense
either i alois with letter of intent or
memorandum of understanding from the
customers that this is going to be
deployed or some form of contract
forward-looking contract when the
product is ready
they will buy the x amount so those kind
of commercial traction is really
critical and maybe the
one other area with the product will be
as is really the pilots
trying to understand these are
non-commercially commercial but at the
beginning it's more about testing the
product and making sure that it meets
the customer demand customer
requirements so we focus on those two a
lot it icario i i don't describe series
seed through c what i tell people is
that we're looking for post product or
product of almost done so a lot of the
technical risk is rung out and starting
early commercial
i mean very much like bearish and
i'll just say one more thing before that
typically but like the last company we
invested in
was thanksgiving a company called haley
microgrid technology company but i've
been following that for four years
already i met them i met the one the
co-founder technical co-founder when he
was a grad student at mit and presented
to the national renewable energy labs
like i have this great idea for how to
do microgrids it's okay
but it took a while a lot of these you
have to
meet them early and follow them for a
while and see which ones end up and then
at the time of productization is where
we get in
a border board observer around all of my
companies and so do a lot of the like
planning out milestones with ceos and
even i need to be able to as we're
investing like
there's a million different ways people
draw this i think each round of
financing is like you're running a set
of experiments and
you have some outcome there that you're
tying to a value inflection point and so
you think of have everyone drowned like
when you start a company when you're
raising money and it's going to keep on
changing but that whole idea of here's
the first group of experiments i need to
run to have a value inflection point how
much money does that cost then add nine
months right uh where can i get
non-diluted financing my our companies
use a ton of great money sparta ending
just birs coe like everything to go
across a bunch of different areas and
then really just always be refining that
thesis of what are the value inflection
points the experiments you're running
and the outcomes that that you can then
raise on and it's a new set of risks the
thing that always screws the finance to
nowhere right they're in the middle of a
super expensive
part of a development plan or something
like that and then they go trying to
raise money and they've really proven no
more than they did the last time they
tried to raise money and stage and
strategy also depending on what sector
you're in there's certain
rules of thumb for how long it takes to
get a company to cash flow positive and
we i tend to look ask
when people are in front of us
fundraising okay this is nice but what
are your total capital formation needs
to to cash flow break even
and if there's say an enterprise sas
company like salesforce took around 70
million or so if they're saying they can
do it on 10 million
to get to that kind of the scale of
salesforce in 10 years in probably not
unless something really crazy has
changed and so you just learn these
things over time
and
also you talk to your really smart
friends like ernest b barris and julia
to figure out what it is but but always
whenever you're investing coming you do
want to be aware of what is it going to
take to get this to is it a 50 million
exercise with multiple people is that a
10 million exercise to get to that point
i feel like we should just stop talking
and say bottom line collect people who
are really good friends who are much
smarter than you that's pretty much the
goal to success
or the
right
yeah surround yourself with good smart
people
um are there typical exit patterns that
you've noticed for these deep tech
companies that might differ from other
companies or what would you guys
consider as successful outcomes for
these jeep check investments you guys
are making
specs are going to be one big angle for
non-healthcare i guess like healthcare
is different but it's especially in some
of these companies who have long-term
revenue horizon
specs seems to have a different risk
reward profile
than some of the later stage venture
capitalists and also time pressure again
the specs are being raised in an 18 24
months of time fuse so they need to
deploy the capital i think they raise as
much as their 70 or 80 billion dollar
raise last year which is as big as u.s
venture capital market and this year
they are on a 200 plus billion dollar
run rate
if they continue raising at that pace so
it's another 200 billion dollar looking
for acquisitions
uh and there are many companies to
acquire the stages they're going earlier
and earlier and yeah they're buying
companies which kind of arrived so
my take is spec is going to be a big
exit avenue for the deep tech
in for the near near term and
i don't know like maybe healthcare julia
can tell more about because it's been an
established market with exits
yeah and i think the interesting thing
is i feel like i've talked as if all i
do is therapeutics it's just so much
easier from a playbook but it's not all
i do and even in healthcare i actually
do a lot of robotics and automation for
you know people-free drug discovery like
that's
we're probably gonna have to take that
public i don't really want to
i'm scared of that right that's
not ideal and so we're still writing the
playbook in a lot of those and i think
in areas of so biocheck it's easy right
the milestones are what's going public
when that is going public pre-clinically
like barely at the reason seriously for
some of those um a lot of what i do in
more industrial biotech
and bio and other areas like that you
have the traditional you end up with
some of the same issues from a liquidity
and exit point of view that you have in
traditional markets so there's some
awesome case studies about materials
investing and why it's like an absolute
horrible idea and all of us are still
doing it because now it's due tech right
um and then then you you're like we're
gonna do this totally differently and
then you end up you know on the board of
one of these companies and you're
scaling it you're like oh we're gonna
have these same issues
of like this this customer that we
thought maybe could acquire the whole
thing now we've got this whole business
line and this other thing they have no
interest in and are we gonna have to
split up the company do we have to take
this public now there's definitely some
playbooks that are still being written
in some of those spaces
yeah i i laughed when
julia was talking about materials
investing
most of the companies you'll invest in
will
not go public
they'll go public if they're creating or
segmenting a new market and if i think
back to my arduino time like the real
real right online authenticated luxury
consignment mapbox is
probably going to go public eventually
because it's creating a new mapping and
geolocation platform
other companies in industrial
the the supply chains and the buying
and the distribution channels are so set
up that you're more likely to be bought
up have your startup bought up by one of
those companies who's trying to fill in
a hole or gap in its whole solution for
its customer base
now
everything
every so often something comes along to
make everything new so this ev
transition means that
tier one oh you know tier ones are no
longer the only ones who can sell
directly to oems startups can now sell
directly to oems like luminar to volvo
in lidar it really depends but i would
say most of the industrial type
investments in tech investments are
going to be an m a by a bigger
industrial concern who already has
distribution and reach unless like an
eevee's the market the whole stack is
being blown up
and then you have room for new things to
happen i'd also say this probably is a
good problem to have but it's a problem
i have right now that is
the big problem in terms of liquidity is
if you are lucky enough to have
something go public early but then
you're sitting there and you're like
it's been in 10x but i think it's 10x
more
and crap it went public too early so now
i actually have to make a decision on it
and possibly piss everybody off because
i just want a bunch of money on the
table so like things going public too
early can be a problem too
your lps will always be mad at you
for that unless someone some people have
told it like um not at this one but we
don't pay to be public market investors
and especially when you have
institutionals like pension funds and
others that have to provide dividends or
things there they want the liquidity
because they have to turn around and
sell it within a few days or six months
a different discussion distributed 50
at an 8x
held on to the balance of the 50 with a
trial readout and so no one left me
final question for the panel i'll let
you each answer one of two questions and
limit your response to one minute each
both are questions from the class so
question one option one is what do you
think is the next ecosystem that will
become deep tech
and option two for answering is
if you had to start a company right now
which industry and type of company would
you make
so answer one of two questions i'll let
julia start
cheers so next ecosystem for deep tech
what's the city to move to for deep tech
yeah
and which industry would you build
something in
it's also the billion dollar question
right here i actually i'm gonna be a bit
contrarian on the ecosystem one and say
don't move to austin don't move to miami
i still i think i think in deep tech you
wanna again it goes back to this
ecosystem work and
great books written on on on ecosystem
development where it's go where there's
talent there's corporates there's phds
there's all those inputs you may not
want to grow there anymore so a lot of
our companies that we're starting were
so my investments cambridge
seattle san francisco i'm talking about
like my
bay area like the ones that have done
the best new york minneapolis because
there's a lot of neuromodulation in
minneapolis but you go where your people
are and maybe you scale somewhere else
but you have some core there so i'm
actually not going to try and call the
new market i'm going to say there's a
reason why some markets are the markets
they are um yeah i guess the first one
was the rich vertical the second one
which city ecosystem right quickly the
first one i would say i guess the
ignorance is bliss
so i it's hard for me to pick the areas
that i know a little about so the ones
that i don't know much which looks very
exciting and a lot of things are
happening is one of these quantum
computing and the second is the
computational biology a lot of
interesting stuff happening in there uh
but i don't know anything in both so
it's good to easier to call them out the
rest like autonomous space and all that
stuff you have a lot of scars on our
backs yeah the ecosystem-wise i agree
with julia it's you could build uh
companies where you can have the right
type of folks around you and it's really
hard to build it everywhere i invest so
my investments are in pittsburgh denver
la oregon in portland one of the biggest
challenges hiring it's great like with
the core of six to ten people
any of those locations will be fine but
then once you started to scale
hiring is distributed
yeah
by the way i should say the caveat is
changing a little bit in covid
we're working on a grail spin out which
just holds illumina and like now the
team can be anywhere so i it's not
really bay area it's actually
canada-based
but
so maybe that's going to be a little bit
different now
yeah i take the understood the questions
a little different but if i take barris
and julia's month yeah go where the best
people are because you create the best
conditions for an intentional and
unintentional serendipity and have the
resources to build interesting companies
and have interesting things happen
thankfully there are types of work that
can be done remotely and in other places
and i'm
glad to see
many more sort of centers of excellence
popping up all over the world
and across the us because we knew that
in terms of when you said ecosystem
version i took that to me what sector do
you want to be in next and for better
for worse i've made my choice for the
next 10 years we have 10 years to i
don't want to
sound too like socially impact oriented
but we have 10 years not to cook the
planet and fix a lot of things if you
think about pick a survey but we have a
thousand gigawatts of
generation here in the us and to get to
a net zero grid you need somewhere
between in the next 20 years we need
somewhere between three or four thousand
gigawatts so a tripling of that
multi trillion dollars of spend and so
that's a massive market
the flip side is it's been hard to make
money and energy
and renewables and all that other things
but it's a massive market and it's and
we have to fix the carbon load problem
in the world before because my son's
going to be off to college in 10 years
and
he's nine now and i don't know what
we're going to be leaving him
so
the trick is to make finding a fine
there's got to be something in there
right there's that much money moving in
and there's a lot of deep tech that
needs to be applied and scaled up not so
much developed but really scaled
absolutely big challenges we need to
solve